[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sion par
lespaul au rendez vous qu'il ne faut
absolument pas manquer si vous êtes un
amoureux du sport local on est le
vendredi 7 juin et nos chroniqueurs ne
sont pas encore en vacances présentation
en musique de la dream team
on commence à ma droite c'est le
zinedine zidane du cyclisme il fait des
miracles avec son bidon c'est notre
choco l'europe et vice champion du monde
master le capitaine yann jarrier club de
vélizy 78 et allemands ne gagnent le
zinedine zidane quand même si senna je
trouve que c'est trop c'est trop a c'est
trop la zizou pour moi c'est ça fait
partie des icônes quand même ça c'est
donc vous êtes quad il rami sait je suis
pas fou le bord de la touche on peut
dire ça on passe de l'autre côté à
musique elle nous vient tout droit de
versailles allait aussi sensuelle que
doué sur les barres de pole dance c'est
toujours un plaisir de la recevoir notre
ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange est avec nous
pendant une heure très bien mais je suis
ravi d'être là kantari vendre des
traînées en plus hachée avec le zinedine
zidane du cyclisme chanson avec tous
leurs amis apparemment il est trop
modeste
on passe de l'autre côté musique qui
nous vient lui aussi de versailles c'est
un chroniqueur redoutable qui n'hésite
pas à plaquer ses adversaires dans cette
émission pierre chevalier du rugby-club
de versailles est avec nous bonjour
tiare salut michael lui à tous formés
bonheur grand talent et ça va très bien
plaqué vous adversaires
oui et pas et pas d'autres adversaires
féminines on passe de l'autre côté
musique lui aussi adorent plaquer ses
adversaires elle ajoute ce à la seule à
un humour redoutable la légende le mythe
notre super chroniqueur ex-entraîneur de
plaisir jean miss est avec nous quand
allez-vous très bien on vous sent très
concentré pour ça que je suis là je suis
préparé j'ai révisé tous deux des câbles
on leur fait peur entre oui mais c'est
pour ça j'ai dit médiation entre nous
allons maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de football l'ex entraîneur et
joueur du psg laurent fournier a signé
avec le club de poissy vous font
également un coup de projecteur sur le
foot us les templiers d'elancourt perdu
en demi-finale de conférence mais avant
de développer ces thèmes on va parler de
football féminin du football féminin
donc pour commencer l'équipe de france
débute son mondial ce vendredi 7 juin au
parc des princes contre la corée du sud
les joueuses de l'équipe de france se
sont entraînés ce lundi 3 juin à
clairefontaine malgré une météo un peu
capricieuse des jeunes de croissy sur
seine ont pu assister à la séance depuis
les tribunes et encourager leurs
protégés pendant plus d'une heure on les
écoute
j'aime bien ça me donne envie de crier
allez les bleus
bien si on les voit pas tous les jours
c'est des professionnels allez les bleus
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on peut les
voir c'est
c'est des choses professionnel s'est
passé c'est magnifique table donne envie
de devenir peau de l'égalité après les
tribunes direction les terrains la
matinée s'est terminée par une séance de
dédicaces avec les joueuses tous ont
voulu un souvenir de cette journée
mémorable et cela a fait plaisir aux
joueuses de l'équipe de france de la
compétition approche plus plus agrandi
pour iliad effervescence donc c'est bien
pour nous ce positif les enfants ils
sont pleins d'énergie donc on en prend
c'est bien à lyon ça fait plaisir
en plus il ya beaucoup d'enfants et
c'est vrai qu'à notre âge en bas on
rêvait quoi de ça il faudrait aussi
c'était une belle surprise munster
agréable l'équipe de france s'est
entraînée à croissy-sur-seine à huit
clos pour le dernier entraînement avant
le match ce jeudi la question sur ce
thème quand on voit ces images le
football féminin peut-il rivaliser avec
le football masculin
vous votez oui ou non via que vous
décidez ont fait un petit duel entre
jean et pierre alors genre ou non pour
vous non non notre question donc pour
moi mais pour us et c'est le propre du
sport féminin actuellement c'est
malheureusement mois il suivit alors
encore là elles ont la chance j'essaie
retransmis les chaînes de télévision sur
la capacité sur les accaparent d'autres
tant mieux pour elle mais jusqu'à
présent quand même il ya beaucoup de
diffusion et donc pas beaucoup de
d'engouement et d'intérêt pour le sport
féminin
il ya un peu plus maintenant mais de là
à ce que ça vienne au même niveau que le
football masculin j'y crois encore trop
précoce fond oui pour moi c'est trop tôt
beaucoup trop tôt ça viendra peut-être
mais pas pensons il y aura pas même avec
les retransmissions il y aura pas le
même
- qui a eu pour la dernière coupe du
monde masculine ça je suis certes et
pierre chevalier c'est à vous et moi je
pense que c'est un contexte favorable
cercle si on parle médiatisation et
sport sur ces deux points là son côté
médiatisation on est emmené en pleine
évolution on est en plein en pleine
construction du du football féminin est
son impact là ce qu'on va ce dont va
profiter c'est justement que la coupe du
monde soit organisé en france
on sent déjà le buzz
depuis quelques jours seulement c'est
peut-être la différence par rapport aux
garçons c'est qu'une coupe du monde
organisée en france en 98 on en parlait
déjà depuis depuis de longues semaines
là le buzz et la médiatisation est
arrivé un petit peu tard mais elle est
là c'est donc là on en parle beaucoup
toutes les télés sont branchés pour pour
le match france corée de ce soir et est
donc là on va on va bénéficier justement
de cet engouement là en terme de
mobilisation on voit on voit les jeunes
mais qui sont mobilisés sur le tard mais
ils sont là côté sportif c'est c'est
encore évidemment assez déséquilibré
mais pour répondre vraiment à la
question en disant est ce que le
football féminin peut rivaliser oui
après ça sera ça s'inscrira dans le
temps
ça sera peut-être pas tout de suite ont
en revanche quand on voit des équipes
comme la mecque et l'olympique lyonnais
avec les tripes le titre de championne
de championne d'europe
elles ont elles ont des palmarès que
certains que certains clubs deux garçons
n'ont pas donc donc là c'est sûr que
nous on est on est en retard on est en
retard de ce côté là sur la mise en
avant et la médiatisation mais peut
rivaliser oui sur le côté sportif le
l'attrait des matches de football
féminin et là j'entends des gens
entraînés ce matin par les internistes
siens de canal qui justement parlé de
parler de la retransmission des matchs
de foot féminin jusqu'à maintenant avec
une seule caméra est désormais ça va
évoluer il y aura plus de caméras et
donc plus de possibilités de montrer la
vitesse du football féminin
l'élégance est là et le côté technique
et aériens du football féminin qui de ce
côté là n'a pas grand chose à envier aux
garçons qui sont un petit peu plus
physique ou sur l'impact juste mon
physique
donc oui côté sportif je pense qu'on
peut rivaliser ça prendra encore du
temps mais les la coupe du monde en
france est une très belle étape est une
très bonne étape pour justement
médiatisé le
il a juste rajouté que on le voit on le
voit quand même le match d'ouverture a
lieu au parc des princes et non pas au
stade de france
donc c'est déjà quand même si pour avoir
un stade sont % plein et un stadier
football donne justement donc justement
c'est bien la preuve quand même que ça
crée pas l'engouement attendu peut-être
où ils sont encore conscients que ça va
pas se lever les foules puisque si là
ils ont fait le match d'ouverture de la
coupe du monde au stade de france
après ça s'est jamais vu par là
finalement à un match de ce type au parc
des princes donc je vais pas tant
d'autres c'est pour ça que je dis que on
est en union en éloignant go hélène
savoir un stade plein et comme disait
pierre on est juste en face un décalage
énorme de médiatisation de temps
d'organisation entre hommes et femmes
après si on compare avec les coupes du
monde
masculine poule ou même pas du tout
comparé finalement iliaque l'otan qui y
voilà qui peut faire des choses
après il faut voilà il faut des
partenaires il faut plus de
communication plus de tout ça mais au
niveau il ya performance is it également
qu'ils passent à la télévision avec qui
met en scène les joueuses de l'équipe de
france oui mais je n'étais absolument
pas le cas il ya encore cinq ans vous le
dites c'est c'est trop récent en fait
pour qu'ils puissent encore se soient
inscrits dans les mentalités des
personnes que le la coupe du monde
féminine le foot féminin a le même
impact que le foot masculin les réseaux
sociaux qui sont ils très là pour le
coup très long à dire peut-être en
avance sur la partie télévision et les
footballeuses féminines sont assez
présentes sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment il ya une une pub qui a fait
il ya fait pas mal de buzz sur les d
international à le monde justement qui
compare à kiki qui casse le dow qui
casse les clichés justement de
comparaison entre les femmes et les
hommes au football qui a fait pas mal de
buzz et je pense que là on va voir les
killian les adil et boubacar qui vont
être remplacés par dans l'est dans
l'esprit des supporters par par wendy et
autres filles dont on va parler c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
jusqu'à maintenant mais elles vont être
sur le devant de la scène vient du jard
y est vous a pas encore entendue sur la
question
vous étiez plutôt de l'avis de jean je
suis allé moi je pense qu'on va vivre
alors déjà que la première chose c'est
ça va dépendre des restes de l'équipe de
france est en effet je pense que qu'elle
va aller très loin parce que bon depuis
depuis quelques années ils sont toujours
présentes elles sont toujours dans le
final fort des demi finales de toutes
les belles compétitions
maintenant le gros sous voilà ce que je
pensais qu'on va vivre avec elle toute
cette compétition et on va les
accompagner jusqu'au bout et j'ai peur
que derrière eh bien elle retombe dans
l'anonymat très rapidement parce qu'il
n'y aura pas de suivi c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui on a le droit de voir la
finale de la ligue des champions
2 féminine caire transmises en général
sur une sur une chaîne de la tnt
et c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas énormément
de phares on n'en parle pas et on en
voit pas le quotidien de deschamps du
championnat de france on ne voit pas le
quotidien de la ligue des champions on
ne voit que les derniers matches lareau
anonyme pour vous pour l'instant
complètement complètement et donc pour
moi on va avoir un gros focus pendant
quatre ou cinq semaines la sueur sur la
coupe du monde féminine
on va en parler énormément mais derrière
jeu même si l'équipe de france et c'est
vraiment tout ce que je souhaite est
championne du monde
mais même si elle y est même si elle y
arrive
le soufflé peut retomber le sont pas
mais le souhait mais pour moi je pense
j'espère me tromper mais je pense que le
soufflet retombera très rare moderne
c'est justement à cette a7 à la c1 pour
l'instant un effet de mode et il ya
beaucoup de débats en ce moment je livre
on est ce que c'est la même chose le
foot féminin le foot masculin en
retransmission il ya quand même en ligue
des champions il ya la finale enfin pas
la finale en d1 quand le psg rencontre
l'olympique lyonnais féminin c'est la
même chose c'est le choc du layon donc
aller aller retour cela il ya là il ya
un peu de trop de retransmission de
médiatisation
mais j'ai vraiment envie d'y croire dans
dans l'esprit et dans surtout dans
l'état d'esprit dans lesquelles les
filles à bord de sa en disant il n'y a
pas de raison qu'on ce qu'on puisse pas
être comparables après il ya il ya dans
le temps un gros décalage de
médiatisation est mise en avant on l'a
dit mais j'ai envie d'y croire à cet
engouement là et à cette fraîcheur qui
qui semble poindre pendant la coupe du
monde et espérons le après ce qui est
sûr c'est que les supporters
du foot masculin du fou du foot que l'on
peut voir tous les jours et dont on
entend parler tous les jours vont
découvrir beaucoup vont découvrir un
nouveau football et je pense qu'ils ne
seront pas déçus parce que techniquement
c'est vrai que les matchs de foot
féminin sont beaucoup moins chez sont
enfin c'est beaucoup plus agréable à
regarder
justement est-ce que ça plaît genre
c'est l'éternel débat mais bon tout ça
c'est à dire bien ça va ça va moins vite
j'ai c'est sûr que techniquement c'est
peut-être plus vrai plus encore jeu égal
jusqu'à maintenant le technicien le site
et 110 on sait filmer que d'une caméra
un seul plan qui écrase un petit peu la
perspective et surtout qui ne rend pas
du tout l'impression de rêver pas
l'impression le rythme et la vitesse que
le foot féminin ou produit désormais
qu'ils ont une caverne la coupe du monde
a priori les différentes chaînes
impliqués vont mettre plus de moyens sur
les retransmissions sur les terrains des
des compétitions et on devrait voir là
vraiment la vitesse réelle comparatif
avec le cyclisme féminin
c'est vrai que on commence aussi à voir
un peu plus souvent depuis quelques
années du cyclisme féminin ou
dernièrement sur les grosses coupes du
monde où justement il y en a
quelques-unes où il ya les maléfiques
cours avec des garçons eh bien on avait
un focus sur les filles pendant 50 km
mais je suis désolé mais oui en effet ça
va moins vite mais les filles elles s'en
mettre plein la gueule pendant pendant
la course donc du coup il ya un vrai
intérêt il ya
il ya un vrai voilà c'est ça n'empêche
que c'est pas pour autant que le
spectacle était moi c'est la nature
souvent une question spectacle sur la
question c'est comme ça c'est la nature
qui fait sa gloire
m à vouloir personnellement c'est un
symbole sam le ça m'énerve un petit peu
ça me manque comme vous qu'on veut
toujours mettre le sport féminin au même
niveau le sport masculin c'est pour moi
c'est pas possible physiquement c'est
pas la même chose ce n'est pas
comparable sinon c'est pas comparable
donc pourquoi essayer de les mettre
alors que alors que dans dans les deux
cas chacun assez assez assez charme ses
avantages ses inconvénients
mais on ne peut pas comparer mois pour
moi sa moindre fait le job alors comme
il parle de cyclisme je peux juste une
parenthèse sur le rugby
mais le rugby c'est sûr oui c'est pas
mal mais ça va beaucoup moins vite
il ya beaucoup plus de fautes de mains
c'est vous ce sera beaucoup moins vite
c'est pas comparable pour moi on peut
pas comparer donc je pense qu'il faut
arrêter d'essayer de mettre le scorff le
sport féminin au niveau lisbourg
masculin c'est pour la prochaine c'est
comment c'est complètement déséquilibré
s'est inversée donc c'est un milieu très
très
du coup lui mais bien dans les airs mais
voilà c'est complètement déséquilibré
donc évidemment après au niveau des
performances ont fait pas de différence
nous au niveau de la pole entre les
hommes les femmes les femmes pratiquent
comme des hommes les hommes comme des
femmes chacun a des styles vraiment très
différent et les capacités physiques
même si elles sont parce qu'on est on
est physiologiquement différent même si
les capacités physiques sont différentes
on peut quand même faire des
performances égales nous dans les deux
sexes alors à priori ce qu'un plus
gracieux à la pole dance de moi une
femme que qu'un barbu
mais c'est parce que tu dis ça parce que
c'est un peu comme en foot on est
habitué à voir des hommes faire du foot
est en pole en habitué à voir des femmes
ça va réellement moins vite égal à
roland garros par exemple les derniers
billets qui sont vendus ce sont toujours
les billets pour les demi finales
féminines
voilà donc il y à dire qu'il ya un
attrait qui est moins important et
pourtant justement il ya peut-être aussi
une question d'argent aussi d'un
football masculin il y avait beaucoup
plus d'argent que dans le football
féminin
alors pour rappel c'est techniquement il
n'y a pas de joueuse professionnelle de
football en france puisqu'il n'y a pas
de ligue professionnelle cent soixante
et une sur 290 joueuses de division 1
dispose de contrats fédéraux qui leur
permettent d'être rémunéré les joueuses
gagne 2494 euros en moyenne un joueur de
d1 masculin touche en moyenne 100 8422
euros mensuels c'est l'histoire
voilà les raisons de l'être c'est une
énorme différence c'est surtout pas
comparable on a le plus gros budget
celui de l'olympique lyonnais avec 3,5
millions d'euros et l'équipe masculine
de l'équipe de l'olympique lyonnais ses
285 millions dont s'arrête ça résume un
petit peu l'attrait l'attrait de des
partenaires déjà des télévisions aussi
malheureusement avec avec ce statut qui
êtes-vous le site y est et c'est elles
sont sous contrats fédéraux seront en d1
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de contrat de
deux livres des professionnels ne sont
pas professionnels ont finalement donné
complètement il y en a énormément le
l'armée de football féminine en d1 d2
qui qui ont deux emplois et qui galèrent
qui galèrent mais ma journée debout
quand elles quand elles quand elles
quand elles s'entraînent assez loin et
qui est qu'ils sont qui sont pas
tellement plus haut que le smic
en cumulé en cumulé entre un emploi et
le
defour pour vous pour aller pour être
une grande championne au niveau de la
ligue 1 je suis fan ligue 1 féminine je
suis à peu près sûr qu'il faut la même
quantité d'entraînement qu'à un mec qui
fait de la ligue 1 masculine et bien
commencé abc mais si le lan trésor dont
la charge d'entraînement sauf que les
filles et ben à côté de ça elles vont
pas elles vont elles vont aller bosser
elles vont aller bosser à côté et les
mamans vont s'occuper en plus de leurs
de leurs enfants
donc c'est honteux je suis désolé c'est
honteux il ya eu il devrait y avoir 10 %
de prélevée sur les salaires des
footballeurs du faits ni masculin qui
devrait être reversée au football
féminin une proposition où l'équipe
latéral de l'équipe nationale 2 dames et
100 pages féminines pour cette coupe du
monde là est en gros financé par les
garçons qui ont ou qui ont lâché une
partie de leurs primes c'est les filles
les primes que les flics
la prime que les filles pourrait avoir
si si elles sont championnes du monde
c'est ridicule par rapport à ce que les
gars ont pu y avoir alors les garçons
coop du groupe a besoin d'argent
ben la prime ils peuvent se permettre de
la deûle à donner d'aussi à sion et d'en
faire et d'en faire don ce qui est très
très bien mais là les filles elles ne
pourront pas elles auront besoin de ça
pour pouvoir avoir une prise de position
du dernier ballon d'or le premier ballon
d'or féminin donc et norvégienne qui ne
participent pas au mondial justement en
ayant pris une position assez drastiques
côté fait ni féminin et défense du foot
féminin en disant que les conditions
n'étaient pas réunies par notamment par
la fédé norvégienne pour participer au
mondial dans de bonnes conditions donc
elle a valsé elle se met en retrait donc
on a le ballon d'or qui qui ce qui
participa au mondial il ya également une
petite polémique à clairefontaine
ces derniers jours les gars ont pris
place dans le château et les filles ont
dû déménager dans le domaine de la
voisine à clairefontaine donc c'est
juste à côté de clairefontaine du centre
d'entraînement pour leur laisser la
place comment réagissez vous ceux
viennent en sachant qu'il y avait trois
équipes en même temps y avait des jeunes
également été la porte un bon là elle
joue une coupe du monde c'est quand même
qualification également pour la danse
masculine
fait il joue il joue quoi les jouets la
norges pas quoi la foire était bon faut
arrêter c'est un manque de respect là
par contre là ça va bien pour moi c'est
un manque de respect elles sont
installées 100 parce qu'ils vont pas
dormir une fois dans le château que ça
va leur faire passer de manque de
respect il faut préciser essais dixit
brigitte henriques qui est là quel
vice-président de la fédé de foot
disaient elles ont profité de
clairefontaine pendant pendant deux
semaines je crois pour préparer le tout
quand les garçons sont arrivées elles
ont déménagé à la voisine car un château
juste à côté les experts qu'aux faits
tout en continuant à profiter les
installations sportives les terrains de
clairefontaine et j'étais dans les
caisses de le disait ce matin elle dit
on était super bien reçu à la voisine
il n'y a pas de grosse différence elle
était hyper bien c'est vrai c'est vrai
que le geste jet le geste fait que c'est
elle qui sont délogés les garçons garçon
sait jamais mais il faut dire qu elles l
ont profité pendant deux semaines de
quarantaine château du rugby de changer
de thématiques un dernier message pour
pour les bleus allez les bleus alors on
continue à parler de football mais cette
fois ci à masculin laurent fournier ex
joueur de lyon saint-etienne marseille
paris bordeaux et ancien entraîneur
d'auxerre de nîmes de strasbourg du red
star du paris saint germain a signé pour
un an à poissy un club qui évolue en
nationale 2 il nous explique son choix
au micro de tv 78 déjà pour retrouver
les terrains de me faire plaisir
mettre en pratique ce qu'on a appris
depuis pas mal de temps
et puis avec un objectif de formation et
de faire monter la n 2 en national on
écoute maintenant la réaction de son
président il nous explique comment se
sont passées les discussions avec
laurent fournier lui même avait l'envi
je pense c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
grosse tête c'est quelqu'un qui
effectivement n'est pas venu pour la
valeur de l'argent ça ça m'a beaucoup
plu et c'est un critère aussi parce que
ne pas oublier que l'exploit s'y est pas
un club un puits sans fond donc je vais
être très honnête avec vous ça s'est
fait très rapidement un an de contrat un
salaire vraiment plus que correct et ça
m'a beaucoup plu
la question sur ce thème fait-il le bon
choix
je parle bien sûr de l'enfant ni fait-il
le bon choix
oui vous êtes partage et il avait le
choix entre quoi est quoi voilà ce que
je pense que si l'arrêt imposé ses choix
pour la table maintenant maintenant en
effet je pense que ça va être une belle
expérience
je pense que ça peut être très sympa
aussi 2
d'apporter tout son savoir un petit club
régional ou même pas d'accord mais voit
ces groupes mais par rapport à ce qu'il
a pu voir et connaître avant merci après
son parcours on voit qu'il est quand
même très très fidèles eux il y avait
vraiment une vraie empreinte c'est à
dire qu'il a quand même et à
saint-etienne il a aidé à lyon il a été
à paris il est allé à bordeaux en tant
que joueur il a entraîné un peu aussi et
toute la france strasbourg auxerre et
c'est donc il a il a une vraie une
fréquence très content bien sûr qu'ils
restent dans le championnat de france
par contre par contre par contre il est
il est des yvelines quand même à la base
il est innée des idées du coin et donc
donc du coup je pense que c'est très
sympa et une chose est sûre c'est que
les joueurs
j'espère qu'ils vont avoir un vrai
implication parce que là il va y avoir
une vraie progression il pas une vraie
belle progression
parce que l'accompagnement qui va leur
apporter ils ont peut-être pas eu
l'occasion d'avoir autant de qualités
ces dernières années jean vous étiez
partagé oui je suis partagé parce que
j'avais la même question et que yann le
choix le choix toko et quoi parce que si
c'est le choix de venir entraîner poissy
là qu entre delhi 2016 voilà c'est le
créteil lusitanos voilà est-ce qu'il a
eu vraiment le choix certainement une
opportunité plus pour moi c'est une
opportunité puisque le choix donc après
et c'est bien mais c'est surtout bien
pour le club et l'équipe les joueurs
parce que comme l'a dit yens c'est un
garçon qui va amener son expérience et
en plus ils ont un projet de montée en
national donc là ça va être
c'est tout bon mais c'est tout bon pour
le club et les joueurs qui à mon avis
ils vont êtres vont être attentif à ce
que l'art au conseil et aux
entraînements qui va pouvoir mettre en
place un joueur et un entraîneur de la
trempe de laurent fournier
c'est uniquement pour ça après
personnellement je pense que c'était où
il allait entraîner là où il n'avait pas
d'autre proposition donc
jours après qu'il a refusé d'autres
challenge également blessé par balles
dans le vide hautmont parce que sion
après c'est pas comme vous avez dit
c'est pas non plus le tard de dalea
nationale 2 avec un projet de montée en
national surtout qu'il est quand même
bon là il ya un pas en fin de carrière
puisque là ce n'était qu'un entraîneur
pendant très longtemps mais mais bon
pour moi c'est une plus value pour le
club et les joueurs
plus qu'un choix moi je pense que c'est
une sollicitation les voiliers sur les
images là je pense que karl olive le
maire de poissy n'y est pas pour rien
pour rien un ancien du foot l'ancien
canal et donc je pense que ça dieu ça
dure est une sollicitation qui répond
pour reprendre ce que disait yann qui
reprend je pense à un désir une volonté
de se poser une volonté en eau
domestique puisqu'il est du coin de
pouvoir se réinstaller dans les yvelines
et puis peut-être d'y faire différence
ou trop juste à côté est d'ailleurs
juste à côté du futur sont entrain de
médiane d'ailleurs de dieu du psg est
fait pour reprendre ce que disaient les
uns les autres
c'est une très bonne chose pour le club
de poissy vont pouvoir en bénéficier de
son expérience de son réseau et de celui
de karl olive si en même temps mon avis
et ça va être très bien pour policiers
pour le foot à poitiers qui est gagnant
finalement dans cette association hélène
à votre avis le club et pour moi plutôt
le club après lui c'est sûr c'est
l'opportunité de ré entraîner de de
montrer un peu d' amener son expérience
et c'est enfin son expérience et de de
montrer aussi qu'il est capable de faire
grandir un club avec ses termes et je
pense que c'est plutôt que tout le club
avant contrats c'est pas trop court en
effet faudrait deux ou trois ans un
projet de montée en national qu'ils y
arrivent à voir laurent fournier pendant
une saison
montez division et s'il vient à
disparaître derrière ça va être un gros
après c'est un an mais qui sera
peut-être contre nous
mais c'est vrai que non il faut
jour les problèmes financiers également
pour ces clubs là il ya environ huit
cent mille euros de budget à poissy
forcément prennent un risque même s'il
ne touchera pas à grand chose
apparemment sur son expérience ils
prennent quand même un risque financier
en en ayant pris parce que ce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'on suive parce que
c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir de belles
histoires on a vu des ddd un trader
prendre des clubs alors moins chevronnés
moins renommés que laurent fournier
mais prendre des clubs niveau national
et les montées jusqu'à des très bons
vins vrai jusqu'à la lie je crois qu'il
ya un inventeur qui était monté standing
un tout petit une petite ville de la pwa
cité en ligue 2 voilà donc en voie site
avec la trentaine d'années avait voilà
longtemps à l'antenne de le dépanner
on n'était pas les mai mai donc
donc voilà vrai bien sûr que bien sûr
que ce sont des ça peut être une belle
histoire ça peut être le début d'une
belle histoire maintenant tous vince
faire étape par étape mais il ya quand
même beaucoup de choses qui voit son
petit doigt ce anticipé parce que voilà
on sait bien que dans le football ou
dans le sport de haut niveau
le nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent
mais c'est un projet global de la ville
de poissy ça peut ça de sam peut être
avec des jeunes un régal je veux mourir
si j'ai donc s'est fait remonter le club
intégrer des jeunes avoir une tête
d'affiché eux qui entraîne et je pense
que c'est une volonté globale de poids
si tu vois mal à sortir un joueur comme
mbaye niang par exemple qui joue
aujourd'hui à rennes mais qui est passé
par le milan ac et d'autres écuries et
qu'ils allaient rester 80 points
sélectif c'est vrai de ville un projet
de club et du rail sûrement que fournier
il ya trouvé son intérêt pour pouvoir y
répondre et faire ce choix
on va passer maintenant notre rubrique
focus et on continue par du basket
[Musique]
l'entente le chesnay-versailles 68 a
connu un week end magique les seniors se
sont imposés ce dimanche de juin face à
paris en finale de play-off de
prénationale sur le score de 92 à 60
vous avez bien entendu 92 à 60 un
résultat qui leur permet de remporter le
titre en ile-de-france est de monter en
nationale 3 nous avons reçu le lundi 3
juin l'équipe en plateau on écoute le
coach tout d'abord de la fierté puisque
c'est le travail digne d'une saison et
même depuis que je suis arrivé au
chesnay versailles
et puis un soulagement d'accomplir
d'accomplir cette saison et de ne pas
trébucher lors de la dernière marche pas
ce qui est arrivé jusqu'au final fort cd
c'était déjà quelque chose et et puis
bah avec le graal au bout c'est encore
plus beau quand l'équipe va donc monter
l'année prochaine et va devoir recruter
pour tenter de se maintenir ça sera
l'objectif du club
il y à un paramètre à prendre en compte
certains joueurs ont de la bouteille
c'est le cas de ben basât qui a 40 ans
par exemple la question sur ce thème le
plus dur est il à venir vous votez oui
non à vous changez barre d'entrée des
alors gens vous avez été le premier à
prendre votre petit et forcément
forcément il y passe y passe du niveau
régional au niveau national et au basket
c'est c'est compliqué parce que parce
que là il va falloir qu'il recrute
énormément et est autant un joueur comme
bembe bamba bamba mamadou bah fallait
qu'il m'excuse
bamba a pu et leur apportera encore
on le voit là et leur apportera encore
certainement par rapport à son
expérience l'année prochaine ben ali a
connu la nationale à la nationale 2 la
neige sauf que là il a 40 ans et là
les pays on peut pas on peut pas faire
autrement que que quelqu'un vole l'âge
de ses artères et qu'un nationale 3 ça
va être un peu plus compliqué pour lui
de pouvoir suivre le rythme ensuite
l'expérience il aura toujours et ce sera
toujours à mon avis un joueur un joueur
clé du groupe
mais il va falloir qu'ils s'étoffer
normalement pour pouvoir se maintenir la
première année parce que c'est toujours
le l'objectif des clubs
lorsqu'il monte d'une division qui reste
qu'il faut de sauvegarde les vieux
briscards dans l'équipe
évidemment évidemment s'ils peuvent
s'ils peuvent le faire oui parce que
c'est le plus dur reste à venir parce
que je ne suis pas sûr que c'était
vraiment une
un objectif de la saison de monte comme
ça et finalement il ce petit à petit on
en parlait sur ce plateau ils sont
paysans passer les étapes
ils ont ils ont joué pour gagner on en
parlait lors de lors de la dernière
émission désormais dix sont en plus
avaient sur un score un peu fleuve
lorsque contre le paris basket
ils y sont attendus la mayo à duke
rendre grâce justement à ces anciens et
grâce à l'expérience d'un d'un joueur
comme bombassei et ils ont besoin mais
plus que jamais en nationale 2 de cette
expérience des gros matchs des grosses
oppositions des déplacements de cette
exposition qui va être un tout petit peu
plus importante
donc oui besoin besoin de besoin d'
anciens pour encadrer et accompagner le
accompagner la montée qui est un vieux
briscard est ce qu'il faut garder les
vieux briscards dans l'équipe de chelsea
ces vaisseaux mais j'ai quand même un
souvenir d'un kareem abdul-jabbar qu'à
jouer en nba vu quand même hein donc
atteint joueurs par exemple vince carter
à 42 ans
si je ne me trompe pas joue encore une
ville donc
en effet c'est à 40 ça commence à être
un peu dur mais mais ça n'empêche que on
peut encore progresser les techniques
d'entraînement nous aident à à pouvoir
mais voilà sa demande ses relais ça
demande une une vraie une vraie
implication
j'en parlais cette semaine à
l'entraînement c'est que avec un avec un
copain je disais si on avait roulé aussi
sérieusement à 20 ans que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on aurait eu une
autre une autre carrière l'une ou d'une
autre carrière sans avoir été brillant
mais enfin plus brillant plus jeunes
mais mais c'est vrai qu'on aurait eu
l'âge fait que l'on va on va on va aller
plus dans le détail sur certains sur
certains aspects et qui vont nous aider
justement à pouvoir maintenir notre
niveau ou à progresser nos moubamba a
une vraie expérience du haut niveau
il sait ce qu'il doit faire pour être
pour être efficace je pense qu'il va
encore encore lui est resté quelques
années au niveau nationale 3 il n'y a
pas de bras pas de souci et puis surtout
quand on le voit on écrit il à laon il à
l'envi donc à partir du moment où on à
l'envi il n'y a pas de ya pas de y'a pas
de soucis mais en effet il va falloir
que parce que ça repose pas sur un seul
joueur et l'équipe il va falloir un peu
de renfort pour pour pouvoir se
maintenir et ça va être l'objectif
l'année prochaine le coach olivier pain
va rester ce qu'il faut confirmer un
coach qui monte
ouah juste avant la question des tiers
je dirais j'aurais tendance à dire oui
en règle générale quand même je rappelle
un peu l'historique il ya un plaisir
vous n'avez pas été confirmée en rugby
bien sûr là vous n'avez pas été
confirmée en montant fédéral du d'accord
oui le rappel historique où les services
sur bien sûr alors la logique voudrait
que oui quand même parce que ben et il
est arrivé il fait partie intégrante de
la réussite pour cette montée donc pour
l'avoir vécu et puis pour avoir vécu pas
mal de montées en tant qu'entraîneur je
sais que c'est c'est le résultat d'un
travail d'une communauté avec avec les
joueurs et d'une mise en place qui prend
du temps et dans tous les sports c'est
la même chose sport collectif
donc là le travail il est en cours il a
déjà une avance sur le collectif
et si par malheur le club se séparer de
son entraîneur mais il perdrait du temps
parce qu'il faudrait que le nouvel
entraîneur remettre en place un nouveau
collectif et année en étant pas sûr que
les joueurs adhèrent aussi bien qu'ils
ont pu adhérer avec cet entraîneur l'a
donc c'est un risque
un entraîneur qui monte mais on doit
rien changer parce que justement la
mayonnaise a pris
ce passif à ladite leur sinistre et donc
donc ils sont restés comme ça il faut
rester dans cette dans cette spirale de
victoires et d'engouement collectif
pierre voulu ajouter oui je veux juste
ajouter que sont comparés à tous et à
tous les autres sports
le basket somme semble que je le
pratique pas mais semble permettre
justement d'être compétitif encore à 40
ans la récupération est plus difficile
mais le l'impact physique et peut-être
et peut-être plus
plus doux que d'autres sports je pense
au rugby par exemple où là il est il est
difficile de jouer de jouer déjà après
35 ans au basket on peut on peut espérer
qu'il soit encore compétitif il jouera
pas il sera pas dans le cinq majeur à
chaque fois il jouera pas tous les
matches mais c'est ses joueurs
expérimentés doivent apporter sur et en
dehors du parquet dernière question
hélène ce qu'il faut qu'il vise le
maintien
l'année prochaine on va évidemment de
toute façon c'est ils sont tellement
attendu la dette remontée avec un
résultat pareil le matin et pas plus au
moins ça déjà franchement si voilà s'ils
peuvent confirmer toutes leurs
stratégies leurs techniques l'entendre
qu'il ya dans l'équipe et un bon
recrutement et après évidemment que on
doit pas s'arrêter juste a confirmé son
maintien mais c'est ce sera vraiment le
minimum algérie pourriez-vous me kyi qui
vise plus haut mais ce que si son
objectif le métier ils vont avoir ça
dans la tête toute la saison et au
niveau psychologique c'est ça peut être
un mauvais signe alors que si mettons il
disait
le résultat sera le même mais
psychologiquement c'est différent il y
des baies il faut qu'on arrive à finir
mettant dans les quatre premiers c'est
l'objectif de finir dans les quatre
premiers
là on n'aura pas on n'aura pas son mot
maintiennent dans la tête toute la
saison
en tout cas on leur souhaite bon courage
pour cette montée on ouvre de nouveau
une page football décidément dans le
championnat de régionale 3 l'étoile
sportive de trappes a terminé de la plus
belle des manières sa saison en assurant
à la fois la montée en régionale 2 et le
titre de champion de régionale 3 lors de
cette dernière journée se sont imposés 4
1 sur leur terrain contre les mureaux
dans le même temps boulogne billancourt
qui était premier a perdu 4 à 2 sur le
teint doni forcément c'était le feu à
trappes on écoute les réactions cette
première place qu'on occupe et on est
trois quarts de l'année ça fait vraiment
plaisir tout le mérite en revient aux
joueurs au staff aussi kim a un qui
m'accompagne la direction qui m'a fait
confiance cette année est vraiment fier
aussi de terminer meilleure défense de
la ligue de paris sur la saison on
encaissé 12 buts c'est énorme c'est
énorme c'est vraiment peu c'est une
grosse saison 6 0 5 buts par match et
c'est ce qui a fait notre force et cette
saison très fier de pompes temps tant
d'années qu'on cherchait sa le club il
ya beaucoup d'investissement de joueurs
d'efforts de sueur
de rigueur et away très fier de faire
pour vraiment monter ce club moi
l'équipe la régionale 2 un niveau
attendu par les trappistes depuis 35 ans
pour réussir sa saison prochaine le
staff veut conserver son groupe en y
ajoutant de l'expérience avec un
objectif en tête le maintien
la question sur ce thème est-ce que
c'est plus jouissif de gagner à la
dernière journée
je galérais toute la saison et d'arriver
à la fin ils ont pas l âge de saison
ajouté trois quarts beauté les dollars
romilly l'ont pas des lettres saison ils
sont repassés deuxième où ils ont ils
ont bagarré le lendemain ils arrêtent
isobel dirais pour aller chercher mais
ça n'a pas été de la galère la galère ça
aurait été d'être deuxièmes ou
troisièmes toute la saison
et puis bah au dernier moment les
équipes des équipes qui précèdent
s'écroule
la voilà et là là c'est pas le cas ils
ont été à la bagarre en effet moments de
moins bien mais comme tout le monde peut
la voir dans un championnat
après s'il n'y a pas des fêtes de
boulogne billancourt soit dernière
journée ils ne sont pas champions
eh bien là c'est la réussite c'est la
réussite qui fait le qui tu fais le kiki
fait le groupe tic ou bien sûr que sur
ce dernier match il avait une chose à
faire c'était de gagner
et d'espérer le faux pas de le fou de
boulogne une fois qu'ils ont gagné ben
voilà ça c'est fait non on a rempli
notre contrat on a fait notre job et qui
bat oui la réussite fait que boulogne
boulogne se planter et donc ben voilà le
titre
maintenant l'objectif en début saison
c'était de la montée en r2 il l'avait
déjà de toute façon atteint au début du
et l'attendent depuis 35 ans rit mais il
avait déjà atteint depuis le début le
début de début du match avant avant le
match donc de toute façon l'objectif
était et est réalisé mais dans la saison
et et aurait été belle jean qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
la toubib
donc gagner sur la dernière journée pour
moi ça me fait penser un petit peu une
finale
pour moi c'est comme si j'avais gagné
une finale c'était pas contre
l'adversaire direct alors c'est pas
comme dans l'adversaire direct c'est
pour ça que j'y mets un bémol mais sûr
je veux dire sur le sentiment sur la
sensation ça revient quasiment à gagner
une finale où on plutôt hommage aux
montées voit la marge augmenté puisque
ils finissent premiers un but s'ils
montent au niveau supérieur sur la
dernière journée
donc c'est vrai que ben je pense que
s'ils ont eu le sentiment et cette
impression de victoire soit pour moi je
montais soir soit pour gagner une finale
c'est ça doit être la même jour la fête
et plus belles finalement les mêmes que
j'allais dire qui ils sont là ils
attendent ils ont fait ce qu'ils avaient
à faire ou au maximum et après demain
c'est le voile assez c'est si je
l'admiré s'est quasiment assuré donc
dans tous les cas il y monte mais on
peut dire que voilà je n'en suis pas sûr
qu'il ya toujours un truc où tant que
c'est pas fait on attend et au moment où
ils ont eu les infos ça doit être ce que
tu es juste jouissif dont vous parliez
c'est surtout sur les l'effet de
surprise parce que ils ont bagarré
pendant toute la saison il était quand
même dans les plaques de leurs objectifs
avec la montée de voter dans le top-100
montée acquise cette cerise sur le
gâteau avec un titre c'est à la dernière
journée oui oui ça peut être jouissif
parce qu'il ya ce côté surprise de ce
qui n'était pas prévu pas forcément
attendu et c'est c'est jouissif à la
fois pour les joueurs le staff et les
spectateurs qui étaient un jour 9 ce
jour-là en apprenant en apprenant la
nouvelle parce que ça se fait aussi pour
partie à distance comme six mois sur la
fête on avait des images un instant
fumigènes voilà confettis normal c'est
l'esprit du cellier foot voilà donc
si on l'a pas là on l'aura ou dans les
lacets du tour de france et puis ça
s'arrêtera là maintenant bien sûr qu' il
faut arrimer le quand les coureurs
passent l'alpe d'huez
ils ont aussi fini jeunes dans le fameux
virage des hollandais mais donc dont on
en revient sûr que le foot c'est
l'esprit
voilà les champs et caetera et et tant
mieux et je me souviens l'avoir vécu
l'année dernière avec pas les autres qui
étaient aussi montées de r3 envers deux
et c'est vrai que c'était c'était très
sympa de souvenirs pour les joueurs et
pour les pour les pour les gamins parce
que là ils étaient là et c'est vrai que
ils le disent on est champion alors
c'est en opposition des champions de
rien du tout mais le champion de
facteurs de régionale 3 voilà à mai mais
c'est vrai que c'est ces cinq hits voilà
et c'est ça qui fait naître net relève
est là
ils sont trappistes voilà c'est leur
club c'est l'heure c'est leur commune
ils ont ce club dans le dans le sang ils
ont ce club dans le coeur et est donc
bien il est décédé communion c'est des
vrais partage petite pensée pour
mustapha larbaoui qui a un qui a dû
faire le job évident d'honneur de la
précieuse manqué de faire notre job à
son poste
on continue par du football mais cette
fois-ci américains les templiers
d'elancourt cale en playoffs de deuxième
division ce samedi 25 millions et été
battus par les gladiateurs de la queue
en brie en demi finale je score 15 à 10
conséquence ils ne monteront pas la
saison prochaine en première division
on écoute les réactions d'un entraîneur
très très grosse déception je pense que
on passe complètement à côté du match
comme on l'a dit en fait à la fin aux
jeunes aux joueurs en fait c'est nous
qui donnons le match on se tire des
balles dans le pied en fait tout
simplement on a un problème d'attitude
de
bah de fautes répétées qui
qui nous qui nous pourrissent la vie
depuis depuis quelques années il faut
vraiment qu'on règle le problème parce
que parce que c'est c'est trop triste
d'avoir un potentiel comme le nôtre et
de d'avoir des résultats en fait si vous
aussi mauvais un petit mot sur les
gladiateurs de la queue-en-brie pierre
chevallier ne trouve pas chaque sujet
sur foot américain en france je j'ai ce
petit plaisir de découvrir le nom des
équipes des équipes et des championnats
des différents championnats je trouve ça
hyper frêche je vous enverrai internet
fois mes roulés j'aille me renseigner
aussi en tout cas c'est la deuxième
saison consécutive qu'ils perdent en
demi-finale de conférence je parle bien
sûr des templiers d'elancourt la
question sur ce thème la saison et elle
a raté oui
raté oui je suis aux hellènes sont ratés
ils sont abattus ils sont c'est tout
genre bien sûr que c'est pour la
deuxième saison j ça fait quatre ans
d'affilée qui sont deuxième division
sont envoyés à malras mais ça fait deux
ans qu'ils échouent lundi vingt deux ans
qu'ils échouent en demi finale donc bien
sûr la déception est là parce que parce
qu'il n'arrive pas à accrocher justement
ce cet escalier cette marche
supplémentaire qui leur permettrait
d'accéder à la division supérieure donc
après on entendu c'est l'entraîneur
qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure dans le
reportage
bon il est consciente quand même
mais d'après ce qu'ils disent c'est un
peu dommage parce que si c'est
l'entraîneur il se dévalorise un petit
peu parce qu'il dit qu'ils ont les
moyens ils ont des supers joueurs et
qu'ils n'y arrivent pas donc c'est
peut-être un problème peut-être mentale
parce qu'ils ont gagné quand même cette
victoire mais cette saison dont une
seule défaite et ils perdent dès qu'il
ya un match à élimination directe
l'hiver dernier match ici l'intérieur à
la lucidité de dire qu'il a les moyens
de montrer autre chose et qu'ils n'y
arrivent pas où il faut qu'il se fasse
aider où il ya quelque chose qui cloche
parce que si et scylla
cette lucidité en disant j'ai de bons
joueurs on a un gros potentiel mais on
n'y arrive pas quelque part il se met
lui en porte à faux
en dix ans et qui n'est peut-être pas il
propose peut-être parce qu'il faut à ses
joueurs ce match et n'a cédé qu'en ce
côté mental que vous que vous citiez en
tout début de saison
septembre octobre il semble avoir évoqué
sur ce sur ce plateau tous ensemble le
premier raté potentiels auraient ils ont
payé on attend aujourd'hui c'était jean
viard janvier je savais que c'était une
début un début de saison et on en avait
des on avait déjà parlé à ce moment là
d'une équipe peut-être sur courant
alternatif et avec avec en gros quelques
problèmes de motivation de mental et qui
se voilent à aix est confiant son début
de début de saison et puis là
malheureusement ça se vérifie encore
avec un match à élimination directe où
l'équipe est pas au rendez vous pourtant
mieux outillés sur le papier mais mais
pas au rendez vous donc oui il doit y
avoir un problème de préparation mentale
plus que physique ou tactique d'un
problème mental
pas mieux ouais ouais enfin un problème
mental problème problème tout court on
se souvient mis beaucoup de pression
cette année on va gagner tous les
matches et puis cliquer 53 des cas on va
gagner 30 points voisine et de 50 on va
on va on va mettre des dérouillées à
tout le monde et puis le premier match
ben on gagne d'un point donc en effet
c'était c'était quand même un peu un peu
compliqué de débuter comme ça ils se
sont bien rattrapés ils ont fait qu'une
défaite sur sur la sur la saison est en
effet dès qu'on arrive sur les matches
aller match arbres à enjeu eh bien il ya
il ya une problématique donc non ça veut
dire que oui il ya quelques choses à
travailler
est-ce que c'est sur la préparation
physique est ce que c'est la préparation
mentale parce que faut pas oublier un
truc c'est que une saison c'est laval
ils ont commencé en janvier et ça se
finit en juin
c'est pas au mois de janvier qu'il faut
être qu'il faut être optimum c'est c'est
au mois de juin une ligue des champions
les gros clubs les gros clubs de
football ils savent très bien que c'est
pas les matches de poule il faut assurer
la qualif
et puis c'est à partir des matches à
élimination où il va falloir mettre les
ouates et il va falloir être très
sérieux et bien c'est peut-être là
dessus qu'il faut s'inspirer se dire le
championnat on assure on assure de
rentrer dans le dans le final four ou
pour pour aller chercher les phases
finales et c'est aux phases finales où
il faudra être à 110% pour pouvoir aller
détruire tout le monde c'est ça le plus
important
le rugby ben la phase régulière elle est
importante mais pour être champion il
faut gagner mais il faut gagner les
derniers matches
on rencontre les meilleurs et d'un des
templiers ils sont ils se sont ratés
encore cette fois ci c'est et c'est bien
dommage les templiers d'elancourt
reprendront le championnat de deuxième
division en janvier prochain l'objectif
devrait être une nouvelle fois la montée
on passe maintenant notre page débats un
rendez vous qu'il nous faudra absolument
pas manquer ce samedi 8 et dimanche 9
juin dans les yvelines la coupe du monde
de bmx les meilleurs pilotes de la
planète vont s'affronter à côté du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
au total 250 sportifs et 25 pays sont
représentés dont la france qui comptera
neuf pilotes et c'est être brûlées vont
se tester sur une piste qui s'annonce
redoutable avec du vent on écoute le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france au
micro de tv 78 les techniques c'est
l'une des pistes les plus techniques du
circuit mais en même temps c'est une
piste qui correspond bien au profil de
nos français parce qu'on a parmi les
pilotes les plus rapides sur sur le
circuit je parle au niveau des plus
rapide sur la piste
donc du coup c'est plutôt un avantage
qu'elle soit technique on attend près de
12000 personnes pendant la compétition
suez sur une piste forcément très
technique avec du vent
la question sur ce thème ce sport est il
sous coté sous côté c'est à dire qui
n'ait pas mis à sa juste valeur
palinges hérité non pour vous pierre
vous êtes partagés à l'avoir fait il ya
un petit duel entre pierre et hier on ne
passe pas sous côté s'est agacé par ça
dépend sur quel point de vue on se place
ici toujours par exemple par rapport aux
2 féminin est ce que c'est un point du
médiatique est ce que ça d'un point de
vue sportif et que c'est un point de vue
spectaculaires peut-être en tout cas je
trouve qu'il ya de plus en plus de
d'événements et notamment sur le
territoire saint quentinois donc donc ça
répond à hauteur du nombre d'événements
nationaux et internationaux organisés et
ça dans la perspective de peu de paris
2024 où il devrait y avoir encore une
montée en puissance de ce côté là donc
pas sous côtés dans son tableau de
marche pour pouvoir convaincre un public
de plus en plus large
c'est une discipline c'est une
discipline à la fois de techniques
spectaculaires
donc là jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant à
l'ombre du cyclisme sur route ou sur
piste mais mais en pleine progression
donc je pense qu'il est à son niveau
global médiatique et sportif jusqu'à
maintenant et les perspectives des jo et
de l'organisation régulière de
d'événements comme celui là peuvent le
père de leur permettre n'y a pas de
diffuseur en france sur cette
compétition sept manches de man par
exemple donc il reste il reste du chemin
à parcourir si on veut qu'il soit mieux
côté il ya déjà je sais que vous avez
préparé avec le plus grand sérieux
cette thématique oui parce que parce que
c'est du cyclisme ça fait quand même
partie des ddd sport que j'ai que
j'apprécie enfin c'est le sport que
j'apprécie sport que je pratique et
c'est vrai que le bmx moi je suis là la
chance d'aller voir la finale du
championnat de france ya deux trois ans
qui avait lieu à massy et c'est super
spectaculaire c'est à dire que une
manche d une manche arrive vous avez
déjà la manche suivante qui s'enchaînent
c'est à dire que le spectateur il n'est
pas en train d'attendre c'est il ya tout
le temps tout le temps de l'action on va
être sur une épreuve de coupe du monde
c'est le gratin mondial c'est les
meilleurs mondiaux qui seront présents
il va y avoir 280 250 280g les
informations de ce matin 2 204 et
comptait 280 inscrits 280 participants
répartis en deux cent dix hommes et 70
femmes
j'ai travaillé pour une fois les
meilleurs mondiaux seront là le numéro
un mondial
joris daudet lors chercher français bien
sûr s'il vendre et le champion du monde
en titre
le dernière les champions du monde en
titre a gagné le titre en dominant en
2019 2018 ouais c'est ça le champion
olympique aussi alors la côte-d'or field
pour moi illustre inconnu puisque très
très déçu que je ris c'était s'était
planté planté sur le soir et demi finale
aux jeux olympiques donc c'est vrai que
là j'avais moi j'avais une grosse grosse
déception mais met donc voilà c'est vrai
que et c'est un sport qui est magnifique
il y à des chutes jamais des chutes très
grave
en plus donc c'est quand même ça c'est
quand même c'est quand même important
quelques clavicule mais bon ça c'est ça
serait pas bien ça serait pas bien ça va
bien mais voilà ça fait partie du sahel
partie du sport et c'est vrai qu'il ya
une vraie tension et et c'est vrai que
ben le départ est hyper important les
vols que les maîtres que les mecs
prennent entre chaque boss sont justes
fenomeno et puis quand on a eu la chance
de pouvoir faire un baptême
sur la piste olympique eh bien on se
rend compte que ça ne monte pas juste un
pédalage il ya vraiment une technique
pour manger les bosses les gars ne
pédalent très très peu c'est beaucoup de
pompage et de vol voilà c'est quelque
chose de très très spectaculaire et
j'encourage tous les saint quentinois
en tout cas on l'a compris vous allez
vous prendre votre licence car bmx
non alors sur la cij avait découvert ce
sport plus jeunes oui mais aujourd'hui
je suis je pense là je suis trop vieux
n'est-ce pas mieux côté je suis trop
vieux bord parce que même pas de côté
parce que de la piste aujourd'hui
souffrent du même du même mal être c'est
à dire qu'en france il ya le tour de
france chi chi chi tout bois laqué
crasto qui prend toute la part
médiatique et après les autres eh bien
c'est la galère pour pouvoir s'en passer
la parole au zoo si vous êtes passionné
par le sujet hélène qui vous a convaincu
pierre chevalier non je réfléchis où
georges et internationaux je pense que
d'un point de vue spectaculaires et puis
d'un point de vue médiatique c'est vrai
que c'est pas mis assez en avant
maintenant
c'est en ça que je dirais que c'est sous
coté en fait c'est plutôt mal côté oui
c'est vrai après j'aime bien voir yann
qui parle de ça on a l'impression qu'il
a 6 ans et d'élan il est aussi requin il
adore mais non je vois ça en tout cas un
sport extrême qui est devenue olympique
à pékin en 2008
donc c'est quand même assez récent mais
c'est un sport olympique
et c'est un sport qui est apparue en
californie en 1968
ça a été créé en parallèle du motocross
qui était très populaire à ce moment là
aux états unis première compétition en
soixante dix arrive en europe à partir
de soixante dix huit premiers
championnats du monde en 80 2 donc une
histoire un finalement quand même voulu
souvenir du nom de la première
championne olympique
ap ap ap caroline chausson et laëtitia
le corguillé tarek de mai font à l'aide
qui termine mais d'ailleurs j'en suis
tout à fait en 2008 ce sont les 6e
médaille française des juristes l'année
dernière joris murat modèle est
vice-champion du monde aussi donc voilà
les français font partie du top niveau
du top niveau dans ses danseuses dans ce
sport l'outil et voilà il faut enfin
baillif faut les aider quoi faut les
aider parce que c'est pas normal de
galérer comme ça et ce sont des athlètes
complets quoi jean vous avez entendu sur
le bmx
alors je suis moi j'étais également un
grand fan de déranger je suis pas un
grand fan de bmx
mais alors il ya eu une veine du rêve
ils devraient le prendre pour promouvoir
la compétition il vend du rêve
donc il me fait presque mais la
compétition qui m'a aligné ce week-end
je vais essayer je vais essayer la piste
cette saison rien ses 15 balles ces 15
bat pour une journée c'est trop cher
déjà gros intéressé qui aura pas que la
coupe du monde il ya en plus une coupe
de france avec 500 participants et donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
spectacle va être continue et on va
pouvoir en plus comparé justement le
niveau entre les meilleurs mondiaux
oui mais on pourra comparer facilement
le niveau entre les meilleurs mondiaux
et des coureurs de très bon niveau
français quoi et si vous n'avez pas été
convaincus par ian dujarrier c'est aussi
un sport qui est entrée dans la culture
populaire par exemple les scènes de vélo
dans le film itil extraterrestres ont
été doublés par des stars du bmx à
l'époque vous n'êtes que ça n'est quand
même pas tous les éléments pour vous
décider si oui ou non vous allez vous
rien à faire dimanche en yvelines et sa
périphérie ces cas là samedi et dimanche
en demi-finale du top 14 à bord nous
cette émission va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
focus sur une citation de l'ancien
champion de culturisme arnold
schwazenegger l'échec n'est pas une
option
tout le monde doit à réussir je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]